mieux tout le monde s'y retrouve
aujourd'hui pour une vidéo un petit peu
spécial parce que parce qu aujourd'hui
les filles je vais vous apprendre à
faire de la corde à sauter n'ont pas
honte parce que l'auteur on se retrouve
sur un jeu de nos champs et c'est vrai
que moi c'était lui le patron de 6000
effet à ma voix pour qu'elle soit trafic
et comme les tubes commerciaux quand
l'entente petit peu souvent en ce moment
du style 1 j'ai de l'argent j'ai des
mariés sont prêtes à se mettre à poil et
génois de merde
bref tout ça pour vous prévenir que ça
je chante donc si ça vous intéresse pas
vous pouvez quitter la vidéo ou alors
prendre tout au second degré et
bassamois moindre la vidéo chat monde
bis et pour visionnage pegi 18
ces personnes n'ont pas baissé de 4,4 g
[Musique]
glénat